an animated film about a young woman who
fights coronavirus misinformation
is out today priya's mask sees indian
comic book superhero priya
confront fake news around the pandemic
and highlight steps people can take
to reduce the risk of infection in india
particularly unverified claims around
the benefits of drinking warm water
herbal remedies and spices as a means to
ward off the corona virus have spread
rapidly on social media
the animated film in addition to a comic
book
challenges these claims and does more
here's
a small peek
[Music]
i wish we could go back in time ma we
used to go to the park together and play
but now i barely see you
don't be afraid i am priya your friend
and this is sahas why are you sad mina
i miss my friends i have no one to tell
my
feelings to come on let's go on a
journey
have you ever been on a flying tiger
sometimes we have to be strong so those
who love us can also be strong
that's my friend lina's guide
let's say hi to your friend
hi
[Music]
that's my ma she works as a nurse here
your ma has sacrificed her time with you
to take care of those
who need help because of the virus
i am sure she misses you to meena but
right now
she is the hope these patients need
priya we need to stand together
and bring about the change we want to
see that's how we can beat the virus
continue to wear a mask for your safety
and mine joining me now well-known hindi
film actress munal thakur the voice
of the main character priya that's the
young woman
on the flying tiger thank you so much
for
making the time now the cartoon itself
is called priya's mask is the message
mainly about wearing a mask during this
pandemic
or is there something more
you know yes of course it's about the
pandemic it's about wearing a mask
and it's about keeping ourselves and the
loved ones safe
there's this beautiful line in the
animated film that you would see
that sometimes we have to be strong in
order that you know
people around us people who love us can
be strong
this time is so difficult especially
because of the kobit 19 situation we
have lost our loved ones
uh we have to be in inside locked up in
our house
not being able to meet our friends and
family so uh
preask mask is all about kobe 19 it's
about
educating the children because there's
so much fear there's so much anxiety the
fear of
uh you know the fact that they can't
meet friends they have to virtually
attend their schools so it's about
it's a beautiful one uh where
you know we're just trying to uh make
sure that the kids
understand what ko wood
19 is all about how this pandemic has
affected us and
how their parents are their superheroes
so
priya's mask is all about it right and
you like everyone else have also
naturally experienced uh
this pandemic i wonder if that
experience
helped with the voicing priya
yes absolutely trust me the beginning of
this lockdown was
extremely gloomy and very depressing for
me
but my father who's a government
employee have seen him working
all throughout this pandemic and
i realized that he is my superhero
because he's making sure he's stepping
out of the house
he's serving the nation he's a banker
and
after voicing this character when i
reached home
i asked my father if he was doing okay
and
uh i when i told him that you are my
superhero he had that twinkle in his
eyes he almost had tears and it was very
important for our parents
to know from their daughter or their son
that you know
they are their superheroes and they did
make a huge difference in their lives
when i was voicing this character you
know i left like i was
really excited and i was nervous because
this is something that i've never done
before
and uh i always wanted to have
this kind of character who you know so
priya is basic priya's strength is her
power of persuasion
and that's what i resonate with me
speaking of persuasion and people who
worked
through the pandemic people such as your
father
do you think uh that these people who
have been able to carry on with their
jobs or have had to carry on with their
jobs such as bankers and doctors
through this pandemic have got their
fair share
of recognition or have they unduly
had to face problems while they've been
working
uh yes they did not get their share of
you know we
oh that's why probably this is the
reason why we've made this film
so that we we
appreciate the front line workers the
doctors the nurses
oh and just to let them know that they
did make a huge
difference and if they weren't if they
weren't around us i don't know what we
would have
done so uh they did not get their credit
so this is little something that from
from from my team from priya's
mask the entire team we just wanted to
appreciate uh
you know for the fact that they've
worked so hard throughout this pandemic
so just want to say through your
interview just want to say thank you to
each and every
pilot who helped the people from various
countries and got back to their homes
and
you know or thank you to all the doctors
who have treated uh co
with 19 patients uh and trust me this
thank you is not enough
what would you say to those people who
are
hesitant or rather who won't follow the
rules such as wearing masks
or keeping social distance i mean you
see this in india all the time
what would you say to those people yeah
i think we just need to be responsible
citizen
if you like people of whoever i meet on
on the streets if they're not wearing a
mask or all i do is i just go and i
request them if you could just please
wear a mask
you may not your immunity may be strong
but
you may have that asymptomatic uh you
may be
asymptomatic but if you take the virus
home it may affect your mom it may
affect elderly people
it may affect people who have underlying
diseases
so please please not for your sake just
for your sake but for your for the sake
of your family
and for the uh for the people who
already suffering through
uh other health issues please for them
wear a mask take precautions
hoping that they take your advice
pleasure talking to you thank you so
much
thank you so much
india has recorded more than 9 million
cases so far and is the second
worst affected country globally but what
is also driving up numbers is the spread
of unverified claims
to do with the transmission of the virus
and how to stop it
prathiksina is co-founder of alt news a
fact-checking website in india
i began by asking him what kind of
misinformation he had seen spreading
on social media in the country um
it's mostly been health related of late
there have been different strains of
misinformation vis-a-vis coronavirus
there was a time in between when the
pandemic was criminalized and
the muslim community in india was
targeted using false videos and images
trying to suggest that they are
willingly spreading the pandemic
this was in the month of april may but
at present most of the misinformation
that is about conor isis
health misinformation has to you know
have this
drug to prevent kona as have that drug
to prevent chronovice and
very often these are home formulations
um
in terms of you know how hot water and
lemon
have ginger garlic and things like that
besides that
um there's a lot of misinformation about
uh you know homeopathy for example being
used as a prophylactic measure
certain ayurvedic um instrumentations
being used as
for a prophylactic measure which do not
have evidence
and uh this includes the there's a
ministry in india called ayush which
deals with uh areas of homeopathy and
ayurveda and
they have also suggested certain
protocols called i used protocols to
prevent covet but there isn't
much research or published work in this
area
so do you see that this is being spread
with the nefarious
intent all this misinformation or is it
basically people who truly believe they
are helping others
it is not nefarious intent i wouldn't
suggest it is nefarious
it is twofold one um this nationalistic
thing about you know that there has to
be some indigenous
uh solution that has to come about from
traditional medicine you know
the sort of medicines that people have
been using for
centuries and there is a there is a
solution in traditional medicine and you
don't really have to depend on modern
medicine
that is one school of thought where you
know there's misinformation
coming from um the other is
this insecurity around the pandemic
where there
isn't any apparent cure yeah there are a
few you know antivirals that are now in
the market which
some of which have been promising but uh
there is no cure so
it creates a massive insecurity in
people in general and which is why
these uh claims about you know have this
and this is gonna prevent covet have
that and this is going to prevent code
those kind of claims
get circulated uh because you know
misinformations directly lead to
linked to your you know state of
insecurity and
that is the other reason why it has been
so widespread
have you seen any measures pratik to
counter these kinds of
unverified claims
so from the point of view social media
platforms facebook twitter are doing
some
facebook twitter youtube uh but it is
nearly not enough i mean
there's so much misinformation so many
conspiracy theories out there the other
strain of misinformation
is of course the conspiracy theorists
who are out there on youtube trying to
make a bug
uh you're using putting out videos which
are sensationalists in nature
suggesting very random things thankfully
in india
there isn't much of anti-vaccine
misinformation yet it is starting to but
it there isn't
as much as you know countries like us
etc experience
but uh but yeah yeah that that is the
thing uh from the point of view of
government they have a
uh they have a twitter account now
called bib
uh fact check which is putting out some
fact checks but
uh unfortunately uh the fact-checking
handle is very biased in terms of what
content it puts out in terms of
political religion so uh people also
find it difficult to believe that you
know this is a german fact-checking
outlet but
there isn't something done at the scale
at at which it is required especially in
a
country as big as indiana as populist as
india
pratik sinha thank you very much for
that perspective
you